man guys got to come alive over here
because we're going to see some great
gameplay we have some great great game
changers who are going to be competing
here and I use competing as a term
because these guys are holding nothing
back yeah I know it's been super
exciting and we got a chance of playing
yesterday and it's just really fun to
sort of get into this environment you
know what's something that we'd seen in
the movies we were actually in the game
play and somebody here who has actually
worked on the game let's talk more about
what we're seeing here and getting into
this there's three phases to this
currently for in phase one that's right
and also we have some great game
features so one of them pop up in just a
little while I was a VF updates
bullshark moose elk we also have my boy
darkness
aka dankness he will be playing as well
we have a wet feet masterji Star Wars HQ
and so many a lot just cut why not you
know do your thing so anyway here you go
so Star Wars Battlefront - folks now
this is awesome because essentially face
1 you get to its coordinates keep down
the street of feet here and the pressure
is on or the clones have to hold back
vehicle here they do definitely the joys
are or sit there trying to escort that
MTP up the main pathway if they're if
they're successful we go out of that
space - but right now we're saying some
not some specials gameplay from I think
battlefront updates
yeah let's actually talk about the
specialist and also you're going to see
a couple different classes here this
class in particular so master cheese
using is the heavy class specialist
tinier sniper rifle exactly that's what
is easy so the heavy class is great they
got a bit more health in your average
trooper they're also able to pop that
combat shield try to push into area so
you can see those guys pushers or
defenders in some areas but look that we
got one of our vulture droids right now
not sure who's flying this guy but these
guys are great at air-to-air trying to
take out those other ships that might be
coming in that's the blue and one star
fighter otherwise you're there to
provide some great ground support like
we're seeing here trying to get some
strafing runs in on those
oh no come on man yes that's our you
just you just did it wrong there buddy
sorry we all could you have here support
we also have to do we do so another
thing is those air vehicles are great as
trying to take out some of the the
ground vehicles that you may see the
droid army has the a 18 think something
that's really great at troops oppression
although we see here a little clip with
a V wing doing that oh man he's just
mowing some some droids down there
yeah just absolutely trending you're
gonna see this happen quite a bit as
pushing this phase because there's a lot
of open you'll tear right and you can
just come through for some great
straight great bombing runs really and
eliminate as many people to follow the
Canon also uses a presence of an air
vehicle out there players will fear the
skies and they will you know look for
cover in this map where it's really
difficult to find cover to begin with in
this basic thing absolutely and you can
see right now that there is an AAT tank
sitting around on a battlefield
he is probably taken out those clone
troopers with this destroy this voltage
is really stepping it up what I love
about this is everyone's like oh look at
this great open map and then we'll use
our phase 2 is like everything starts
coming in and coming way closer together
and we're talking a little bit more
about the assault class so for somebody
who is just started playing this never
played any previous version you feel
like the assault class might be
something perfect that ever pick up I
don't do it all classes yes absolutely
it's something that that's painful
it's not like I'm surfing that a lot of
players will be able to jump right into
there your frontline flanker attacker I
think they're gonna be fairly easy you
can get right in and just start having
you know your typical running gun action
there's their signature abilities you
see here at the top of the screen your
number two ability that switches you
over to a shotgun you get a little bit
faster and you're able to really get in
there and kind of you know break those
break through those frontline I love it
I love
shotgun man it is so good and it's
actually when I first used it it really
caught me off guard I wasn't expecting
it I said wait a minute
I could destroy people with it I just
charged into the rumen and just
absolutely threaded every weather so fun
to play with here we also see some great
dogs right here between the clones and
the separate discs this is certainly
what a lot of folks love in Star Wars
and just really in any game that dice
makes right they just always do a good
job with the air coming he's really
trying to track him down this is all
just not a vault or could not shake him
well we got the resist you hear you know
he's playing he's playing assault class
again you saw hit he had the signature
thermal detonator that he will be able
to kind of suppress some of those guys
that this rushes in and there are
different different weapons as well like
one of the guns that I would oftentimes
used with the semi-automatic gun it you
know fired a lot slower but you can get
some great shots with it and then
there's also this nice compact SMG style
you know after that really shreds
through people in close range you know
you know I mean we want to give me any
bit more what a variety that's come
around yeah yeah I'll talk some aad tank
action here and this is that's doing
what it does touch compressing that
point trying to keep those clones out of
the way they're trying to make their way
forward as the jelly button-- can you
march down yes get away from that's
right I don't know is you trying to
flank the tank that's not smart
I don't know man maybe maybe he will
maybe in total combat role there give
you some escape options in case you get
into some hairy action oh we didn't get
the P this one before finally no having
some 80 RPS yes so these are Caesars
great was taking out those AAT so these
guys are a little quick they have an ion
charge ability though that way we'll be
able to do a little bit more extra
damage against the tanks as they see it
so you can imagine like three or four
days on the battlefield really rushing
around points like look at this can't a
coffee comin out what can you what can
you like you cannot come over if you
want okay oh I would like she gonna say
could I get shot off of it if I'm on top
of it because my body you
that was that question was answered you
know simple most immediately yeah almost
immediately oh man
so mr. moose elk here you know what for
this guy to be on a tear a little bit
later well and although I didn't want to
highlight we had an officer as a matter
of fact right in front of okay one of my
favorite classes what is it about the
officer that makes it so unique I mean
my my twitch bill is art where they used
to be I'm slower nowadays but I'm able
to to really puff up my class it's off
up my teammate so I don't let them get
some extra help let them push the point
faster what happened nightly finally
some good dog glad to go in there okay
all right and one River Ryder what's
great about some of these starfighters
these are accessed through our new
battle point system so instead of
finding a pickup token on the on the map
like we used to in the last game you're
now able to depending on how well you do
whether you're scoring point to be a
killed via team play assists or you're
playing the objective like we really
want players to do you're earning points
continuously that will allow you to
spend those on whether it be a special
character whether it be a vehicle or
even a hero and the battle point said
that I'll do my houses all those things
definitely and also something to look
out for to when we get to face here
that's been mouth what's really going to
play a role there right right right now
definitely you see a lot more it's an
open space you have confidence air
combat at some vehicle gameplay but once
we get inside it's going to be different
stories that's right things are
definitely beat up and what is this
happening right it's a lock box on shake
him out yep but they better enjoy their
air combat here because that's not going
to be happy to so much longer Oh Matt
much longer doesn't need to destroying
him oh he got the kicked off nice John I
mean he was doing what he did to do a
supportive team right it's a combined
arms fire you want to make sure that
somebody's trying to cover you from the
air oh boy so and you can see after
every respond as well you get those how
many points you earn but registers later
on got some specialist gameplay here as
well maybe you can take
a couple faces perhaps in professional
class you can also deploy different
types of tracks yeah absolutely so they
have access to a trip on so if you want
to get their body with a true sniper
character you set up some trip mines
behind yourself make sure nobody can
flank you but really be there to provide
some of that cover fire your pieces
downrange and it's especially Pope's in
this area because it is such a fake open
area that questions are really shining
to save life the more bombing runs here
and it's absolute caring about map to
say men who so good killing it telling
you to move on yet again doing great oh
let me see there uh one of the officer
classes right next to one of the clothes
officers fantastic for pushing right you
want to be able to push the objective
definitely support your team like if you
are playing with your buddies you want
to be able to have at least one officer
a building and keeps you going in the
fight at least I mean they really help
push you know when those heavies are
trying to drive or at the point
you got your officers behind you giving
you some extra help making sure that
you're not you're still able to complete
that push or on the opposite side if
you're one of the joys you do need a lot
of data point the officers have access
to a turret that they can place on the
ground and you know give it a little bit
more fire support to that area trying to
be massive G here the you know he's
really focused on the bombing lugs right
he's not trying to go into combat with
new so who's up there there's a darkness
49 just shredding everyone up here maybe
I don't get a couple but what is it one
of each mode yeah this is happening oh
yes don't talk about the speech mode
what is how does it play out in speech
mode for a limited time you're able to
blow up some huge area effect shot you
walk down the position but you're able
to have a lot more firepower we also
just saw the b-2 super battle droids
there as well that's um be using another
one my favorite well another one of my
favorite yeah you can grab those guys we
have the battle point systems those guys
great at which points again where they
have high health a lot of rapid fire
oh here we go oh there it is and this
big explosion indicate phase one is over
now we start phase two and this is when
the action really begins to pick up here
because it gets really tight inside of
that building
and the players need to be mindful of
that and look for this b2 to just shred
through everyone especially with that
cooling ability that he has be able to
keep him just as constantly shooting in
the fight he's going to make a huge
difference here at the fighting subside
I mean there's going to be narrow
pathways he's going to be able to just
shred as soon as anybody gets in his way
because it goes north those narrow
corridors could be trouble and waiting
for the prime opportunity to push up
here players falling God now you know
white boy there oh they're all small
action here we go folks
Darvill starts to get interesting they
do get scared Darth Maul will excel in
face-to-face reactor inside I mean he's
a great mobile attacker in essence there
with his life stay below quarters
he always absolutely I mean some of
these abilities you can see here he's
got that squid attack he's able to who
just rush in and out of combat and just
take eyes out the in the process the 20
I was talking to myself earlier and he
was using dark mall and he was saying
how there's public event as well I mean
he was talking about how he wishes Darth
Maul could reflect it would make a
teacher perplexity he's like oh that was
the good flank by public light balls
shredded to clone army unfortunately
they are double that syllabus at Boba
Fett is definitely a hunter-killer so if
the others if the clone army was able to
get some of their heroes in play like
this is where Bobo fellows really
shining with that jetpack in his he's
able to kind of float about the
battlefield fire off some Rockets really
to take out an individual particles with
different PF in the last game from the
last game would give them a bit new
trips he's got a new concussion rocket
though we miss Moorea players completely
he also has that
I said under this one rocket being able
to breathe all done by 9:00 also one
thing mom you told the beats through
here we go but on the clone sighs you
know there are specialists in character
that you can pick up as well we haven't
seen much of it yet but that would be
the clone jumped rebirth that's right
very different from the standard like
assault class or heavy class it has the
jump Jets that you love from power from
the original that's right brought back
here but now focus on a central class
exactly yeah back to the one side here
that's good look at that he's shredding
able to lay down so much firepower to
1000 they don't know now jesse was able
to find him on that one but here comes
from officer gameplay here oh good
finally come to play to support the
force people matter they you know you
kind of give him we're the linchpin of
the team you know yeah exactly now what
is this to bring back to people to
abilities that yeah exactly it's that
healing good it gives you a little bit
of drop for your over health but it also
gives you back up so it's oh we got some
of the jump troopers oh boy and here we
go it's ready for Phase three in just a
little bit there's a jump through but we
talked about them before jump super
super fun to play but again you know
it's attached to a specialist now so not
everyone's going to have any fifth
although it looks really fun in the
original battles right but I'm going to
be excited it
hopping to jump through brings red
people - I mean I know people we love
this people love people love to jump at
oh yeah we got rain oh I I'm super
excited to play inter achieved
she's a quite a powerful character run
I'm sure you know she got out of that
one really don't run quickly but oh they
got all did enjoyed fallen by a finish
Laroy mistake no beret - terry has a
shame
absolutely so raise mind-trick is
something that again all enemies will be
confused for a little bit your controls
we kind of work against you making you a
little bit more vulnerable to attack
just so you guys know this is when again
anything if it be cut and babe there's
so much going on here and hold with that
but that we saw a little ha yeah we're
gonna get some hot I hope so oh but I
mean you saw it earlier so every time
you finish a life will show you how many
battle points you have it some people
have enough points get those
reinforcements and especially this late
in the game you'll see a lot more of
these special classes coming out a lot
more the heroes coming out again this
jump super hero with his rocket launch
with a jump back trying to be mobile
trying to fly into that that last
element capture point this is really
where heavies are gonna thrive and 12
there is my goodness laying down fire
the doorway just absolutely dominating
with clones they need to put out they
need the fight this went out here there
are so many lives left that the
separatists have to their team they
could really run through this opponent
has to start acting fast because if they
cap it that will be it the separatists
will win this game it's not looking so
good for my boys in the Clone Army I'm a
FEMINIST so I'm excited I'll hopefully
go on whichever team wins
oh I'm not going to be too thick in here
jumping ship I understand that you know
no loyalty maybe you are fit that maybe
I am
yeah so in the first place though in
that you're trying to capture that
program you can see here if you remember
it this is the main is the main throne
and it's a lot cheaper close quarters do
you have any leaks or the strategy that
you would add absolutely I'm sure if
you're the cone you're hoping that og
consoles again torn up thank you
it's like Superman at every live force
awakens again you know like don't do it
Darth Maul is just destroying absolutely
everything are there any tips like
taking him down I mean you want to have
a product combined on fire oh oh
the tip is plastered right away maybe
metal a runaway self use the crap out of
start small
oh man he was our MVP look at that my
belt moves out congratulate
[Music]
Bowman
one
sector is clear not my associate
you
you
oh wait Star Destroyer but we can't
declare that escort give it everything
we got
[Music]
your next assignments they are
[Music]
you
clozapine
you